gina tenía dos tercios de taza de
detergente ella usó la mitad del
detergente el viernes para lavar todas
sus sábanas cuanto detergente le sobra
aquí lo que haremos es tenemos
originalmente dos tercios de taza de
detergente y sólo usamos la mitad es
decir multiplicaremos dos tercios por un
medio
veamos qué opciones nos dan nos dan
diferentes respuestas cuanto detergente
le sobra opción a un sexto de taza
porque sería un sexto de taza dos
tercios menos un medio no realmente no
vamos a hacer una resta estamos haciendo
una multiplicación recuerdan en este
caso no estamos restando le un medio
estamos utilizando un medio de dos
tercios
así es que en este caso no funciona la
resta un tercio de taza porque dos
tercios por un medio perfecto nosotros
estaremos aquí multiplicando que es
justo lo que vamos a aplicar dos tercios
por un medio multiplicamos los
numeradores dos por uno y tres por dos
como denominador 3 por 2 2 por 1 2 3 por
2 6 y si llevamos la fracción a su
versión más simplificada tendremos un
tercio así es que un tercio es correcto
podemos colocar la letra b
la opción se nos dice que un sexto de
taza porque dos por tres es igual a seis
no tiene sentido esta respuesta está la
dejamos fuera
punto te voy a hacer un poco de espacio
y la opción de nos dice que un tercio de
taza porque dos tercios lo podemos
separar como un tercio más un tercio es
correcto dos tercios si usamos la mitad
de esos dos tercios tendremos un tercio
así es que si ponemos también la letra d
tendremos la respuesta correcta